Assuming you escaped unharmed, the materials you gathered can be applied in a number of ways,...
...for example, crafting armor that offers further protection,...
...developing more efficient and stronger tools or even building mine carts and rails...
...to quickly transport you between locations.
You might also explore above ground and find a village...
...where you can trade with the inhabitants for various precious items.
Go further afield, and you might notice changes in the landscape.
In-game, these different areas are known as biomes:...
...oceans, deserts, jungles and some altogether stranger places...
...each offer unique resources and wildlife.
Gather these and before you know it,...
...you have a farmstead with a wealth of different crops and creatures you can use...
...for essential food and supply.
Back down the mine, you might find some lapis lazuli,...
...which you can use to enhance your tools and armor...
...on your library's enchantment table, if you built one.
Maybe you'll find some redstone, which you could use to create a whole range of electrical circuits,...
...powering anything from secret doorways to roller coasters that trigger firework displays.
Or perhaps, you'll pour some water onto lava...
...and mine the results and obsidian to create a Nether portal.
Enter the Nether and you will be faced with a whole new world of even more dangerous mobs.
Whilst here, you might seek out a Nether fortress,...
...kill the creatures known as Blazes to collect their rods...
...and you can use those for potion brewing, which would be vital in crafting eyes of Ender...
...that help direct you to the world's stronghold.
From there, you can repair and use its portal to teleport to the Ender Dragon,...
...the game's end boss.